ce qu'ils vont tout changer assez 2001
pour faire un haut personnage qui donne
son avis sur la ténue je trouve ça ne
l'aiment pas non à un million et ça fait
23 % donc je pense qu'ils vont le garder
ouais mais je préfère arthur il donne
des bois sous
[Rires]
dans les bonbons aux invités les bonbons
et au public après quand les invités ils
mangent pas j'aime pas du nord le maquis
d'ochoa sur arte lie l'asie alors c'est
toi combat tu te mets bien asie tu veux
des émissions tout seul n'est pas juste
regarder les amours qu'il faut à peu
près un million 23% tamarins et
aujourd'hui on a trouvé un candidat vous
fait que sa pancarte avec cette jeune
fille celle fils et huit enfants blessés
monsieur chemin qui vous êtes